plongé dans un coma thérapeutique intubé
ces patients sont transportés aux quatre
coins de la france
en allemagne en suisse et au luxembourg
l'hôpital emile muller de mulhouse en
alsace n'a plus de place pour eux au
coeur du premier foyer d'infection du
cône à virus en france le système de
santé est au bord du gouffre
le stock de masques il reste patrick
pote un médecin de famille à lui même
contracté lakovic 19 aujourd'hui remis
il s'est senti abandonné par les
pouvoirs en place
je pense qu'il faudrait que dis-je en
rendre compte plus tard de cet échec là
un échec extraordinaire oui bien sûr eu
bien sûr ils en sont comptables un jour
ces gens là puis on est on est en colère
des médecins le pressait de santé on est
en colère la population en colère après
avoir reçu des patients à son cabinet il
prête main forte aux centres d'appels
d'urgence de l'hôpital en soirée oui
qu'est ce qui nous inquiète madame il
n'y a pas du tout de difficultés à
respirer pour le moment la plupart des
patients en fait appel parce qu'ils ont
un syndrome grippal typique du
coronavirus ne fait presque plus que ce
genre d'appel le
le coronavirus france presque toute la
place le docteur pernoud supervise la
veille de ces auxiliaires et médecins
qui tentent l'exercice parfois délicat
souvent frustrant de rassurer de trier
de prévenir c'est frustrant c'est ça
peut même été choquants pour le
personnel qui travaille parce que quand
on n'arrive plus à pouvoir faire notre
métier dans des conditions comme ça
quand il s'agit de sauver les vies c'est
compliqué pour l'instant ça va
relativement bien il n'y a pas
d'indication à l'hospitaliser là
maintenant tout de suite chez cédera
suriname et je suis moi même inquiet
pour elle parce que jugée peur qu'elle
tombe dans le format avec dans deux
jours elle soit en rien pas rassuré dit
le médecin de famille mais il faut
surtout éviter que tout sauf les cas les
plus urgents se rendent à l'hôpital
en fait l'augmentation du nombre de
patients qui se présentent à l'urgence
de l'hôpital de mulhouse avec des
symptômes de lakovic 19 est elle encore
aujourd'hui que depuis ce matin on ne
reçoit plus aucun patient dont l'état
n'est pas lié aux coronavirus toutes les
autres formes de rance musicale la
traumatologie par exemple sont détournés
vers d'autres services
et malgré cette décision l'urgence ici
débordent tous les jours c'est un casse
tête de trouver suffisamment de
personnel pour affronter la vague de
malades qui déferle
on est en train de monter cette semaine
à mon avis la semaine prochaine aussi
les médecins parlent effectivement des
15 prochains jours où on va continuer de
monter vraiment de monter des bureaux
ont été transformés en chambres pour les
patients en attente de résultats de
tests et de soins la situation en
réanimation respiratoire juste à côté
est tout aussi dramatique
aujourd'hui on a quasiment que des
patients qui ont moins de 60 ans ce sont
des patients qui souvent présente une
évolution de la maladie depuis une
dizaine de jours et qui brutalement
ressemble des difficultés très
importantes à respirer une grande grande
fatigue ne sont plus en capacité de
faire des efforts de la vie quotidienne
et se présente souvent pour ça la france
est en guerre contre le coréen à virus a
dit le président emmanuel macron et ce
n'est pas qu'une analogie depuis
quelques jours l'armée française se
déploie à mulhouse dans le stationnement
de l'hôpital pour augmenter les
capacités de réanimation respiratoire
ici un déploiement militaire d'envergure
du genre réservé aux zones de conflit à
l'étranger dans les prochaines heures
l'élément militaire de réanimation et
ses quelque 30 lits chacun équipé d'un
respirateur artificiel devrait recevoir
ses premiers patients les patients ils
n'arriveront pas directement de la ville
dans nos structures ils passeront
forcément par l'hôpital il y aura une
évaluation de leur état et ensuite ils
iront dans un service de réanimation
classique de l'hôpital et quand leur et
assas une phase d'amélioration les
passions bascule chez nous pour le
sevrage des respirateurs avant qu'on
leur redonne dans des unités de
traitement plus conventionnel 30 lits ça
vient tripler les ressources de
réanimation de toute la région les ici
dans le haut rhin
ce sont 20 à 25 nouveaux patients tous
les jours qui doivent être mis sous
respirateur ça va pas être une goutte
d'eau bien sûr parce que c'est
tranquille quand même qu'ils sont là
mais qu'en fait il ya vraisemblablement
un nouveau saturation le système de
santé n'a pas été préparée du tout à ça
je veux dire en aux hôpitaux n'ont pas
été prévus pour être réorganisée de
cette façon là dans la brutalité le fait
que les patients soient sol n'est plus
une famille qui viennent les visiter
quotidiennement c'est compliqué le fait
que la mortalité soit importante
notamment chez des sujets âgés dans les
services de gériatrie et de mortalité
qui est très importante c'est
excessivement compliqué et tout ça
évidemment pèsent sur le moral de
deneault de nos soignants de nos équipes
le chef des urgences insiste on ne fait
pas encore le tri des patients y sont
tous peu importe leur âge sont soignés
mais pour combien de temps la france
avait jusqu'ici choisi de ne pas tester
massivement les cas de suspicion elle
vient de changer d'avis et procédera
désormais à une détection plus
systématique du virus trop tard parce
que nous se fait trois semaines compte
de tests plus on ne teste que les
patients gardent donc qu'en est il de
tout ce qu'on n'a pas testé qui sont
malades qui sont malades chez eux qui
commencent à être malades ou qui seront
là demain
mulhouse n'a d'autre choix que de
composer avec une épidémie qui n'est pas
contrôlée et son système de santé espère
tenir mais il est aujourd'hui à bout de
souffle